hello everyone and welcome to the final
game we'll be showing from the popular
netflix news series the queen's gambit
uh
it's again uh elizabeth harmon versus
vasily borgov
but it is not the final game of the
series the one that we've already shown
but one of the previous ones
now as usual i'm not going to spoil
anything and
like i said probably the last game we're
going to show and then
at some point i don't know maybe two
weeks from now maybe maybe we can do an
um
a video with an entire overview of the
series you know what's real what wasn't
real
uh what's uh you know what's uh what's
true what wasn't true
and you know what what's possible what
was impossible stuff like that
uh so without further ado let's check
out the game and like i said
if you still haven't seen it do check it
out before watching this video
if you don't want any spoilers and the
the other two
uh videos i made on the series will be
the first and second link in the
description below
so like i said uh the uh the main uh
bad guy vasily borgov has the white
pieces here and
he opens with e4 and in the first video
i mentioned uh sometimes uh during the
game
which game this game was based upon then
in the second video i mentioned
at the end but here i'm not going to
tell you which game this game was based
upon but actually i'm going to ask you
to tell me and then whoever gets it
right i'm going to pin your comment
so e4 we have c5 elizabeth goes for the
sicilian defense as
she usually does we have knight f3
knight to c6
uh and now borgo doesn't go for the open
sicilian but rather bishop to b5 he goes
for the
uh for the median of rossolimo attack
and here we have
g6 g6 is what was played in the actual
game that
this game was based upon however in the
series queen to b6 is played right away
so we're gonna
uh we're gonna stick to the actual game
with the g6 because
uh well it kind of transposes into the
same thing but
we don't actually get to see most of the
game uh in the series just uh some of
the comments from the
from the commentators so here g6 is what
was played in the actual game
uh we have c3 preparing to strike in the
center and now
queen to b6 queen to b6 is one of the
moves we can actually see in the show
as well as a4 uh and here the immediate
a6 however as we have the g6 line
bishop to g7 is what was actually played
with castles and only now
a6 challenging the bishop here uh and
here bishop captures in c6
uh we have queen captures now putting
pressure on the e4 pawn
but we have d4 the black king is still
in the center of the board
and the queen captures on uh on e4 would
be
would be quite dangerous white can then
capture on c5 defended with
uh with b4 and he's going to be doing
very well the rook can come to e1 gain a
tempo on the queen and so on
so as it is very dangerous elizabeth
instead plays d6 and now
rook to e1 by borgov and here bishop to
g4
here the commentator mentions in the
series that elizabeth has an opportunity
here to
open the position up or keep the game
closed
prob probably uh thinking about moves
like c characters on d4 then you can
bring the bishop into the game then
the rook can occupy the c file however
for the moment elizabeth decides to keep
the position closed the immediate bishop
to g4 is played now there is more
pressure on the d4 pawn
as the the knight is pinned here and
here we have
d5 uh borgo now uh grabs more space
attacks the queen
and the white has to react to this so
you could throw in in between bishop
captures because this will come
an attack on the white queen as well
however just queen to c7
uh we have a5 now and a5 is an
incredibly strong positional move
uh because if black ever wants to move
the b pawn he always allows uh
whites to capture alpaca uh and then the
rook will be extremely strong on the a
file and if white
doesn't do that or rather black uh it's
gonna be a problem because this night or
this night depending on what this bishop
does can come for example to d2 uh
not there to d2 to c4 and then uh have a
beautiful
outpost for the knight on b6 and if the
knight comes there with the pawn still
in b7
it's going to be incredibly difficult
for black to play this
so instead we have knight to f6
elizabeth just continues to develop
pieces and
knight b to d2 now now saying okay next
i'm going to challenge your bishop
we're either going to trade on f3 or
you're going to go back and then i'm
going to get my outpost with knight to
c4 and knight to b6
uh we have castles by elizabeth uh and
now
uh h3 challenging the bishop and now it
it would be
a bit weird that the sorry the d7 square
isn't all that impressive for the bishop
so here uh
uh elizabeth just trades with captures
captures and now
knight to d7 preparing to get the knight
the e5
black also wants uh some nice squares
for the bishop
however bishop to f4 sorry for the
knight uh and now getting the knight to
e5 now isn't all that great because
after captures and captures
uh the the bishop will not be all that
impressive there you can kick it away
with g3 f4 and the knight is still
getting uh
the b6 square as the outpost so it's not
a problem
so after bishop to f4 elizabeth decides
that
okay it's too dangerous to allow this
knight to this maneuver so let's just
bust open the position with b5 right
away
and now i have a massive pawn chain or
white is forced to capture ab6
alpha song so this is exactly what
borgov does we have a captures on b6
queen captures now with an attack on the
b2 pawn and
rook to a2 now borgo defense and the
queen to b5 now
uh preparing uh the b6 square for the
knight but also
just just the the rook is coming to b8
so first
knights to d2 uh you still uh have
access to the c4 square
at some point if the queen moves and
rook f to b8 now
we have bishop to g5 putting pressure on
the e7 pawn and just king to f8
elizabeth defense
and now queen to g4 uh putting pressure
putting pressure on the knight here if
the queen is somehow
kicked away from there let's say with a
move like c4 as these
squares will be taken you're gonna have
to go back to b7 and it could be quite
awkward so instead we have h6 forcing
whites to deal uh
with this threat first with bishop back
to e3
and only now knight to e5 forcing the
white queen to move we have queen to
h4 now with uh with a double attack on
the h6 bishop
and g5 now so we have queen to h5
and only now knight to c for forcing a
trade here
uh as uh well this knight could become a
big problem for black however
uh borgo just continues attacking he
says i'm really not interested in any of
this
i just want to bust open the position
and go captures captures captures
if if if possible of course black will
do something to prevent that
uh but okay knight captures on d2 uh
trades off a pair of knights bishop
captures and
now queen to b3 kicking away the
defender of the b2 pawn but also eyeing
that c2 square which will come with an
attack on the bishop here so here we
have rook a to a1
not allowing the rook to be captured and
now
queen to c2 which is very interesting i
mean why wouldn't you capture the pawn
on b2
well here you get rook a to d1 and then
you have to
uh well play a different game because uh
if the queen was on c2 you could bring
the rook over to b2 however this
this way you could for example push the
a pawn if
uh if you think you can survive h
captures and g5 and so on
uh but here elizabeth goes queen to c to
rather
instead of capturing the pawn you can
always capture it with the rook and
you're putting pressure on the bishop
now
so here bishop uh back to c1 not rook a
to d1 but rather
bishop to c1 now guarding the b2 pawn
and g captures on h4 not allowing white
to capture on g5
so now bishop captures on h6 of course
is the main idea
and rook captures on b2 and now already
uh elizabeth is getting the game uh the
the kind of game she wants where she
does have some threats here
and uh if at all possible uh for for her
to
well uh prevent uh all of the checks
then maybe maybe she can do something
this game
however we have bishop captures on g7
this is forced as it comes with czech
king captures and now queen g5 check
uh so here king to f8 and now comes
queen captures on h4 so grabbing a few
pawns
but not only that defending against
checkmate here as the f2 pawn is
defended but also
threatening checkmate with queen to h8
so
how does elizabeth defend here and this
is the the main question of the game
uh feel free to pause the video and
defend this game for elizabeth while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on playing the
move we
never play uh and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
f6 and this is uh something that almost
always loses the game and we always say
never play f6 but
here is the only move that actually
works for for black because if white
continues with queen h8
at least it's not made you have king f7
and you cannot capture the rook because
of characters with
check and then queen g2 checkmate so
you'd either have to
uh settle for a perpetual queen h7 or if
king of
king eight then you get queen g8
checking b7 check
you're going to go back king to d8 and
now you you can either either continue
checking or you have to
say okay i'm going to defend against
checkmate with rook f1 but then rook day
7 comes and well now everything is
defended you don't have to worry about
anything
and uh black nicely survives so
congratulations to everyone who found it
however elizabeth decided to defend
against checkmate with king to e8 but
now
this doesn't really work because borgoff
plays the absolute best move and now you
can see that the king is nicely aligned
with the rook here so just
e5 and now it's a huge huge
trouble for elizabeth you want to
capture here open up the e file for the
rook and the queen still nicely defends
the f2 pawn
so here uh of course elizabeth captured
but the rook captures an e5 which
which comes with a mate threat and again
the f2 pawn still defended
so rook the b1 check at least uh maybe
you can
rattle the white king this way but just
king h2 ignoring uh black completely uh
and
f6 now f6 uh seems like it
it does the it gets the job done but it
really doesn't
so one thing you don't want to capture
right away yes black cannot capture but
you can go queen h7 check and then black
has the
white has to go up the board and it
could be trouble white still survives
this
but you don't want to you don't want to
give
your opponent anything you don't have to
so here borgo again continues in the
absolute
greatest way uh d6 now saying okay if
you capture my real queen captures on e7
uh is checkmate so of course that uh
elizabeth doesn't go for this uh she
starts running away king to the
uh king to d7 uh and now comes uh
rook captures an e7 with check king to
c6
and now only now rook captures on b1
we have queen captures and queen
captures on f6 now threatening d7 which
would come with
check and then well you you have huge
problems here
so queen to b8 by elizabeth not allowing
the pushing of the d-pawn because it's
pinned
but here just rook to c7 checked by
borgov
king to b6 and now comes queen to f3
and it was in this position on mu 40
that elizabeth harmon resigned the game
and uh a wonderful wonderful victory for
vasily borgov and here we even have a
an image from the actual show where
queen f3 was played you can see that the
queen is
a little bit weirdly placed because he
just placed it there
and this is uh well it was a with this
position that i was
actually able to find the the the game
that this uh
game was based upon so like i said i'm
not going to tell you which game it is
but whoever gets it right first i'm
going to
pin your comments so you know do your
best
uh and here you resign because you don't
really have a move there's no defense
against queen to c6 whatever you do
let's say you try
rook to a7 to defend at least somehow
queen c6 just gets the job done king a5
and now queen captures on c5 with
check and whatever you do just loses
because if you move the king
the rook is gone for example king a4
you're just gonna capture the rook
and if you try defending with queen to
b5 uh then it's just captures you don't
really
even have to worry about that captures
with anything loses the rook and again
it's
it's just game there's uh no way for
black to play this
so after queen to f3 this uh beautiful
move elizabeth resigned and
a great great victory for vasily borgov
and for those of you who are just
joining in if you if you've
completed the series or if you haven't
if you're just here to enjoy the chess
but maybe you'll be interested in the
series at some point
uh do check out uh both of the links in
the description below it's the two games
that we've already covered for the show
from the show
and uh well i decided to show this one
as well because i i didn't
want you to get the idea for those of
you who haven't seen it that elizabeth
just you know straight out
destroys every opponent she faces in the
series it's uh it's a learning curve
uh so that's again one of the games
probably the last one we're going to
show or show
from the the show but it might not be we
we might show another one i don't know
we'll we'll see how it goes
uh so yeah i would like to thank uh sean
of herz diego moret robert kiefer
kevin dowd and stephan carp for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
uh i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens uh
in the chess world
so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day